[Music]
okay I'm just gonna level with you I
really fucking hate today's movie a lot
not because the movie itself sides
although it does but because it's a
remake of one of the greatest ghost
stories of all time the hottie
directed by the world-renowned Robert
Wise this psychological and paranormal
horror film played off the fact that you
didn't know how much of the ghost story
was real ghosts and how much was in the
head of our mentally tortured
protagonist you know films like
Paranormal Activity the others or even
the Blair Witch Project where the fear
comes from what you don't see rather
than what you do this is the film that
perfected it and even if you don't find
it scary it's a brilliant character
study and a gothic story it was a
brilliant film back then and it's a
brilliant film right now so director
yonder bond you know this fucker came up
one day and said what does Robert smoke
no he hasn't directed anything good I
mean what does he know when there is
bail just The Day the Earth Stood Still
Sound of Music West Side Story the
Andromeda Strain sand pebbles go on
attack I directed this shit till I can
do it so much better
I know it's Gary I made a tornado growl
so you can imagine this was gonna be an
old versus new of the two haunting
movies but it's totally pointless
there's no contest the old wins but I'd
still like to go over the comparisons
just so I can fight stick it to this
film so I guess this is an old dish
versus new right into a pickle talk
let's take a look at the heart so the
film starts out with a woman named
Eleanor played by Lily Taylor to be fair
not a banner replacement for Julie
Harris she's being flown out for
mother's apartment right after her
mother passed away as you can imagine
she's not too thrilled do you understand
that I have nowhere to go Lou and I are
very busy and we could use someone to
help us with the cleaning and the
cooking looking after Richie I gotta pee
nice meat there kid you could open
Hamlet with that pinky or not to pee so
see how she has no place to go she comes
across a one ad for a sleep study
meeting insomnia X the experiment is run
by dr. Moreau
in the original he was played by Richard
Johnson here he's played by Liam Neeson
oh good the sound of his monotone voice
will put any insomniac to sleep calling
it an insomnia study allows me to create
a highly suggestible environment to
investigate the dynamics of fear so
everybody's off to the haunted house to
partake in the sleep experiment and this
brings me to my first downgrade in the
comparison in this film the doctor is
tricking the subjects to come to the
haunted house for some half-assed not
really explained very well experiment in
the original he just tells them the
truth they're there to study goes that's
much more interesting why fool them into
thinking there's something else it's
just a time-waster are we supposed to be
surprised like they are that the place
is haunted everyone in the audience
knows they're going to a haunted house
fuck it's called the hot egg did you
really think you were gonna fool us next
you'll be telling me that Peter Rabbit
isn't gonna fucking turtle what do you
want so she meets mr. Dudley the
caretaker
I'm mr. Dudley the caretaker and
eventually comes across his wife mrs.
Dudley inside oh my I'm here with the
dr. marrows group you know the first boy
those Dudley's are really like to
introduce themselves in the most
threatening way possible a big outer
gate swinging doors open while holding
knives
how much you want that there's some
greets people with a hockey mask and
chainsaw we live in town 9 miles so
there won't be anyone around if you need
help mrs. Dudley isn't quite as creepy
or awkward as the original they do
manage to handle her scenes ok but then
we get the entrance of our next guest a
woman named Theo play by twisted
[Music]
foster Kade's
the original woman to play Theo did
really good she was fine oh oh he does
he does he to old legs legs legs Oh
George John John's I don't care the last
movie you did stars a schmuck from Julie
one day would be bye seriously they're
piling on the sexy big-time with this
character I mean going all out is there
anything else they could do to possibly
make her more attractive
[Music]
okay so despite how hot that is this
does lead to another downgrade Theo in
the original film is hinted that she
might might be a lesbian or bisexual and
the reason it's best they don't come out
and just say it is because it adds to
the tension between her and Elinor see
half of the movie they're the only ones
that are roomed together and when the
only person you can cuddle up with may
or may not have the hots for you
it makes the scene a little bit more
uncertain than therefore uncomfortable
there was also a possible subplot with
Eleanor having a crush on the doctor and
Theo having a crush on Eleanor but again
it wasn't over the top it was played
pretty subtle
subtlety in this film fuck I'm surprised
he didn't just change your name to lisby
and that's how free and obvious it is
especially because um how do I say this
the 90s didn't always right gay people
very well not that the characters
written weren't proud to be gay no no
far from it it's that they announced it
everywhere they went and to every person
they meet I'm gay
[Applause]
thank for happy this it kiss it spank it
so as you can imagine see the Jones in
this movie is beyond blatant my
boyfriend thinks oh my girlfriend
doesn't it's hard when you're the only
one at the party so what about you
boyfriends girlfriends I could paint
your portrait directly on you just mujer
maybe it was over compensating for past
prejudices maybe the writers did not
write for gay people back then or most
likely in situ Jones's case it's we also
have Owen Wilson as Luke playing the
original by Russ Tamblyn this is right
at the point when the world can tell if
they found him funny or annoying yet why
are you so dominant thanks
do you awkwardly undressing you with my
imagination done so Liam Neeson and two
extras finally enter the house to get
the experiment rolling rest of you may
hate your insomnia but I'm not sure I
want a cure for mine My Mind's racing
with creative ideas and come 3:00 a.m.
oh I will I deserve that I feel like a
genius but Neeson tells them that this
creepy demonic-looking house of death
might actually have a scary backstory to
it
his name is Hugh Crain crane made a
fortune on the backs of workers in this
textile mills now this man could have
anything he wanted but he wanted more
than anything as a house filled with the
laughter of children yeah because I'm
sure a guy who looks like this was a
real big softy with children come on
kids we're going to Ebenezer a Habs
house that's what the fairy tale ends
hewn or enabled have no children
they all died into birth and a few years
later Rene she passed away and Crain
became the total recluse but he kept on
building patting room upon room it's as
if he was building a home for the family
he would never have the townspeople said
that sometimes at night they could hear
sounds coming
sounds of children well good night
let me know how many insomnia goes
where's that need a drink I think
there's more to that story
do tell assistant who only had two lines
before this scene I can feel it it's all
around us it's in the ceiling it's in
the walls it's in this that'll teach you
to try have a part in this movie ten
just for that you and the other guy who
would ever said anything don't be
finished forever never to return to the
script again aw seriously though a
moment of silence for those totally
pointless characters
anyway everyone tries to go to sleep
thus beginning the experiment Eleanor
Jones Wilson the doctor in a minute why
is he going to sleep he's supposed to be
conducting the experiment isn't he
whether it's the insomnia study or the
fear study isn't he supposed to be
around to witness it documented you know
doctor stuff I like the way you comb
your hair like that did I mention that I
was a lesbian I'd be tossing and turning
but many of them can't sleep and find
themselves roaming HR Geiger's
Wonderland
you just don't jump out you all right
down guy you've just bumped into someone
you didn't perform an exorcism I
couldn't sleep I was just insomnia yeah
you gotta be careful cuz I I wasn't no I
know I'm sorry I just oh good god get
over it man run a marathon before you
came to the set where's it coming from
so Elinor and Jones are woken up by a
loud pounding in the night and though
it's not as good as the scene from the
original it does manage to follow the
formula okay I guess
zoo motherfuckers you okay I'm going
back to bed
just leave the chicken on that door look
what did you hear the oh all I heard was
you screaming Luke help me please wasn't
screaming for you maybe I didn't make it
clear that I was a lesbian I don't I
don't see anything I don't hear anything
Wow I sort of got screwed on the old
bedroom selection every room was like
four times as big as mine well that was
my button at the end of us scene to
lighten up the tension what'd you think
not very good was it good now that's not
a bad idea
indicating that the sound they heard
maybe wasn't supernatural but could be
explained by everyday occurrences that's
actually pretty clever let's blame it on
the old plumbing no no no that's good
it'd be all except for one tiny problem
we saw the piano wire undo itself an
attack a person so why would we believe
there's nothing supernatural there when
you clearly showed us there was
something supernatural there but hey
don't worry even that was the case the
very next scene shows clear as day that
ghosts are real
so yeah that previous scene was
completely useless
seriously though a moment of silence for
the completely pointless ena
[Music]
boy the cotton textures on those sheets
are looking a little fake CGI ish aren't
they
well that's just what we call pillow
talk baby and for whatever reason
Eleanor has decided to not be scared by
this the knocking on the door that was
scary as shit but a child's face with no
eyes appearing on your pillow well
that's just enchanting I'm sure you guys
would have the exact same reaction these
carvings are really creepy Thank You
Owen Wilson let's so glad somebody's
here to tell us what's supposed to be
scary in this movie lord knows I never
will figure it out by just watching it
see how my old pal Theo is doing doing
or wearing yeah no kidding do you see
what yeah knowing yesterday
wow yeah I definitely got a soft spot
for Theo but it won't stay soft for long
I deserve that too but things get even
more creepy and I mean that as a figure
of speech when they seem riding on the
wall that says welcome home Eleanor is
this one of your sick jokes Luke what
you really think I wrote that you found
it you could have I want to know right
now who wrote this did you write this
Vito no of course not
maybe it was you maybe you like being
the center of attention
maybe the see because you see what
you're wearing Lady gaga
whoever wrote this
it's cool I didn't do it
have you ever noticed that Wilson's only
job in this story is stating the
painfully obvious do it these carvings
are really creepy
I just think dr. marrows up to something
I definitely got a soft spot for Theo
spinach is green I'm just throwing that
out there
you know all my life I've been waiting
for an adventure and I thought it would
never happen to me and Here I am paint
things are calling out to me strange
noises in the night and all that cost
with five gallons of gas boy she sure
come down from that hole who the fuck
painted my name on the wall thing didn't
she
[Music]
I think that's another down break in the
original story we're falling in love
with the house is well creepy as it
should be it's just another journey to
our psychotic mind surrendering to the
man isn't giving in to her own demented
psyche here it's a comforting see she's
so happy and cured
it's just beautiful ee adventures are
for soldiers or for the women the
bullfighters fall in love with sure glad
they took out all the scariness from
that subplot oh but don't worry when the
actual creepy scenes pop up Owen Wilson
will be there to let us know really
creepy okay I'm listening
so since eleanor has decided to
whimsically give in to what the house
has to say she finds that not all the
ghosts are evil some of them are
actually playful delightful even
[Music]
no you will not give me Laius puns of
fun so unless the message was go on
queer curl for the straight girl she has
no idea what the ghosts are telling her
however she does hear some more voices
leaving her too under the fireplace
Oh God they found Jeff Dunham's lost a
terrorist puppet hey these are the
scares we have to look forward to from
now on folks
CGI about as scary as the wool master
hands from The Legend of Zelda did that
scare you at all well get ready there's
a fuckload more of it really creepy Pete
gilding oh the children from the mills
he wanted to fill the house with the
sounds of children he took them from his
mills and he brought them here but he
wouldn't let them go but Neeson realizes
that his experiment has gone too far he
swallows his pride and confesses that
the whole thing was just a hoax that may
explain what's happening you're
participating in a study on group fear
and hysteria well it's over I'm pulling
the plug
it's real know what a thought that
people would actually be scared in an
experiment about fear taking place at a
haunted house what was he even studying
the fact if you tell people frighten
stories they get frightened you need an
extreme setup like this to tell you that
and how the hell is he studying them you
never saw the equipment or scientific
technology and obviously you can't ask
them how scared they were else that
would get everything away this has gotta
be the worst frigging scientist ever
your theories are the worst kind of
popular tripe your methods are sloppy
and your conclusions are highly
questionable you are a pool scientist so
just as they put Elinor to bed to try
and calm her down the flowing spaghetti
monster comes in to try and cause more
trouble well it's official the house has
turned into a cartoon I'm gonna tell you
Eleanor what's that you're wondering
what the hell that line has to do with
anything well again let's go back to the
original you see they built up this big
scary scene that field was next to
Eleanor company you're supposedly
holding her hand when in reality they
discovered that once they turned on the
light nobody was holding her hand at all
whose head was a now naturally this
scene lasted roughly four to five
minutes building up the suspense and
tension in this film it's one freaking
line do you mean who was holding your
hand when did you ever indicate someone
was holding your hand
did someone grab it when she was shoved
out of bed is that it well that's really
fucking poorly handle you Schmucks
just because you spell a scary line from
a movie doesn't make it automatically
scary that's call that bestbear good I
got trapped god I don't write a book
about how shitty this remake is
naturally I did it told Crosetti this
remake gasps it's a pretty easy read all
it contain
the word as movie sucks this movie sucks
as movie stocks
[Music]
so if she tries to run through the
possessed Cheesecake Factory she
suddenly comes across the good ghosts
and is it me or are they just looking
sillier
what are you trying to tell me what do
you want me to do so she runs up a
staircase where liam neeson tries to
chase her down and talk some sense into
her wait they're freaking apart Thank
You captain obvious
okay it's like his only rule this guy
would have a great job as the laughing
sign for a studio audience fYI I missed
you don't make a big deal out of it just
be happy a celebrity is talking to you
now that was the funny part that was the
funny poor having a great time of great
I want you to come down I'm overstepping
the platform can you do that I don't
know which W sound face to make so just
as they save her and take her away
Neeson encounters his own encounter
Jesus I need to get them out of here
now you know you're gonna pay for Clash
of the Titans
so you're not doing the sequel well at
least Eleanor is saved in her room just
as things are getting crazier and
crazier Eleanor has a revelation that
suddenly has everything makes sense you
see this is the room where Carolyn had
her baby before she ran away and the
children
they wanted me to see this so I wouldn't
know this was my home oh my god yes
Carolyn was my great great grandmother
what and the children are my family
this is where I people okay maybe I
missed something but this was made for
adults right english-speaking adults now
the children are dead no not for him
he's still hunting them but if I'm here
he can't harm them why what the fuck are
you talking about your forefoot nothing
you have to strengthen the Lyman P with
cancer
what's up to senior golf buster
[Music]
[Applause]
and as you'd imagine it only gets
sillier and sillier don't believe me
just watch it with this music
[Music]
so Elinor decides it's finally time to
square off against Wolverines flatulence
by giving probably one of the dumbest
speeches ever uttered in any horror
movie that's meant to be taken seriously
[Music]
you go to hell
you know out of morbid curiosity let's
just see how the oven film is ending oh
wow we're diving much more into
Eleanor's psychosis for insecurities of
belonging or finally getting the best of
her and it just may end up claiming her
life all while the darkness about the
house and her mind consumed what little
is left leaving only the emptiness to
live with clearly these idiots have no
idea how to write an adult scary story
if you'll excuse me I'm gonna write the
one for grown-ups okay mm-hmm let me see
here um oh I know how about crane was
the mastermind the whole time he turns
into this giant evil monster makes all
the scary faces so many complex issues
here all right and then we're messy
Eleanor literally literally defeat him
with the power of law expired
I'm the genius
I'm freaking genius God I lost my
fucking mind there for a second Oh Oh
literally about to go out and in pilyeon
de batata talk about Paul huh alright um
back to the movie
so the see-through Wolfman is destroyed
by like I said before the power of love
and or whatever reason that claims
Eleanor's life
[Music]
we're free our horribly rendered souls
are free and of course only Neeson and
Jones are left to look over the
horribleness that counts as first base
[Music]
what the hell you safe the people who
are already dead and getting it left me
like a chicken with his head cut off oh
fuck this year now I'm going to do Ben
Stiller movies they're intentionally
funny and that's the remake of The
Haunting I don't pick - can we care for
it it's one of the worst remakes of all
time if not be worse I mean when you get
down to it what's the haunting about
it's about family it's not what's not
it's about being scared and I hate to
break it to you folks but redemption
isn't scary
the original is scary there's no cartoon
ghosts dumbass subplot or Disney style
good versus evil scenarios it's just a
ghost story and a brilliant one at that
but hell let's remove that for a second
and just look at this film on its own
it's still crap the effects are
laughable the storia style dish and even
its means of building suspense are
totally backwards and nonsensical it
only gets worse every time I see it it
hurts me inside I hope it burns in hell
like that black bloated Beethoven best
bucket at the end shut up you idiot I'm
the Nostalgia Critic and not even a
bisexual Catherine zeta-jones could save
this movie think about that
[Music]
really creepy
you